well one of one of the things that I I
love about you particularly is that you
are you've got great material you've got
great jokes but you're also a very good
physical comedian you use your body uh
very well well you know uh with comedy
sometimes uh you got to paint a picture
for your audience and uh I believe the
only way to do that is display it
yourself and it's not not crazy things
like oh uh here's an example component
like uh one thing that I do I like I'm
big on shuffling my feet when I get
angry I don't know where this comes from
but I've been doing it for years it's
called the shuffle okay when you get mad
and you want somebody to know that
you're not playing anymore it's a
shuffle watch this I'm not playing I say
get out my face if you don't get my face
I'm capable of killing you right now
see that right there assistant it was
literally about 47 steps like that that
was 47 in my head I count every time I
do it and does that intimidate people
not at all okay they laugh most of the
time people laugh when I do it now I'm
told uh that I know that you have a lot
of success uh when you when you when
you're on the road now but it's gotten
to the point where you've had so much
success and your fans are so rapidly you
have security now is that true well
Conan I mean it's not a secret I'm a big
deal people uh the thing is
you know now it has gotten to a place
where where I I have security but it's
the people I had to go through because
you can't just hire any security guard
you know I went through a couple of
people man this this one guy uh Steve
let me tell you why Steve got fired like
Steve was a nice guy like he started off
great we walked into a club he would
move people out the way he stood by me
like it it looked good he was doing his
job the reason why I stopped dealing
with Steve uh I wanted to go to the
bathroom we walk out the section there's
a Velvet Rope you got to pull the Rope
back we walk to the bathroom I come back
from the bathroom Steve is still with me
the Rope is still there the guy that was
operating wrote he was still talking so
I'm waiting for him to finish this
conversation Steve felt like I shouldn't
have waited anymore Steve decided to
pick me up and place me over the Rope
like listen like as if I was a baby he
went like this
it was the most humiliating thing like
my back leg went up my head was on his
chest
it was bad it was good to go that's not
right there was nothing successful about
that look at all like I heard girls like
um burping I like what no
don't burp me please oh you're cool gone
in a second sex appeal was all going I'm
told that you had trouble with the law
the other day do you want to talk about
that uh well you know calling in my past
I was a thug uh you know it's good for
me to make it off the street so I had
another run-in with the law I got a
jaywalking ticket which was which was
crazy
where did this happen it's funny in that
yeah in Culver City I'm in Culver City
in California uh first of all when you
go to jail a jaywalk ticket is bad
because for them to catch you jaywalking
it's like like it's the stupidest ticket
that you can get like literally like I'm
walking like I'm literally just I'm
having a good time I'm on my cell phone
and the cops they boo boot me I don't
know what it's called but that's what
it's called it's called yeah that's
that's what that's what we say as when a
cop comes like you know
your reaction is always bad yeah sure
yeah and me I was like you got the wrong
man you the wrong guy yeah I'm thinking
this is about a murder like somebody
just got murdered he was dressed just
like me you know he was like you didn't
see that light back there son I said
what
Delight did you not see what you just
did you just jaywalked you disrespected
the light he said that's the rule his
laws here are you serious right now yeah
he's like you need to get off the phone
I was like man no I don't let me call
you back
I was there I was a little scared but he
actually sat there and wrote me a ticket
the worst the worst thing in the world
is trying to convince somebody that
you're like that you're a celebrity is
trying to get him out of it and they
know nothing that you've done I don't
know what you're talking about I said
well maybe you might not want to give me
this ticket because of who I am
this is my face I said yeah
what are you talking about son sit down
when I get the ticket I just had to sit
there like this and wait that's my life
Conan I don't care that's who I am
so what your your heart stops whenever
you're here it just stops no no it's the
scariest thing that should be the your
wake-up alarm
this is my house I bought it I swear
please
I'm not robbing anybody please get out
uh you got to see this uh movie Laugh at
My Pain he's in theaters right now Kevin
you're hilarious thank you it's a
pleasure
take a break we'll be right back